country music stars story of
determination with the help of his
family you might recognize some of his
music check it out
[Music]
that's John Driscoll Hopkins one of the
founding members of Zac Brown Band the
Superstar country music group has had 14
number one hits the life of Hopkins has
been filled with Awards and accolades
but now he's facing his most difficult
challenge Jan Crawford met up with him
between shows Stan good morning well
good morning it's it's really great to
be here I mean John Driscoll Hopkins
like you said Nate I mean he's banned I
mean they have reached the Pinnacle for
sure of success but now he's grappling
with the diagnosis that's changed the
course of his life I met up with him at
his home in Georgia to talk about the
devastating news and the road ahead
[Music]
nestled in a studio in his attic John
Driscoll Hopkins is always creating I'll
take you home best known as one of the
founding members of Zac Brown Band
Hopkins sings and plays guitar for one
of the top groups and country music but
while Hopkins has been enjoying center
stage during the band's summer tour the
51 year old has been facing a difficult
battle behind the scenes I think it was
somewhere around the middle of 2019 I
started noticing I couldn't double time
as quickly as I would still do it but
but I was starting to get angry at my
right hand so it was just in the
movements just in in the speed the speed
and I remember sitting on the bus and
talking to the guys and saying
something's wrong with my hands after
months of testing just before Christmas
last year Hopkins and his wife got the
devastating news doctors diagnosed him
with ALS do you remember how you felt
when you heard that we were crying three
times a day I was just like
I need to figure out what this means
something like this never crossed our
mind yeah it was you're about to turn
50. it was lose some weight it was
everything else
it's called the cruelest disease or Lou
Gehrig's Disease it eventually paralyzes
all muscle movement trapping patients
inside their own bodies there is no
known cure we had done the AOS
ice bucket challenge in 2014.
I didn't even know what it was
you know and I don't think people talk
about it much because it is so
devastating and hard to talk about hey
Opie this is Hope as the father of three
Hopkins greatest fans daughters Grace
Hope and Faith give him purpose oh
and his soul mate she gives him his
daily treatments and courage I worry
about
what it means to her
because I don't want to ruin her
adult life
this is the most beautiful woman in the
world she could find anyone
tomorrow but I don't want to burden this
one
and he's my life
he's your life he's my
mom him and my girls
and he's got so much to give
truly the Stars aligned for us to be
together and we're meant to go through
this together
and
um
whatever that brings whatever that means
this this is this is our our story
breathe in
together they created a charity hop on a
cure which has already raised more than
one hundred thousand dollars for ALS
research his benefit concert in
September at Nashville's renowned Ryman
Auditorium quickly sold out
[Music]
you're doing this for a greater good I'm
not a scientist I'm not going to be the
one with the test tubes and the research
I'm someone who has a platform that that
can explain
I can't play guitar like he used to uh I
I might not be able to sing one day and
if if I have an opportunity to to spread
the word that way then that's my
responsibility we believe that his band
mates have 20 years are standing by his
side God willing I plan to be rocking
with these amazing people for many years
to come they're all amazing human beings
I mean you're like a family and that's
another reason why we've found success
is we
we really mean it January between shows
Hopkins has been working on a different
kind of project
April
May it's called voice banking recording
words and sentences to be used for
communicating in the future like giving
advice to his daughters when he can no
longer talk girls time for dinner
boys are all liars I as a father don't
know what they need yet
and who want to be there want to impart
some wisdom
that that I think they can probably use
later
I mean it seems like there's a song
there I've got three that I'm working on
that are all in different ways directly
related to what I'm going through
what is it that you want to say in those
songs I was writing a
um a song just simply uh I love you
forever
to Jen
hands to the babies and to the girls
did you sing it
have they finished it
can't finish it now to worry in the
world of PBR perhaps that's because
Hopkins doesn't look at his days as
numbered life is good today
but instead as a chance to appreciate
all the good in life
still got it
and with his future unknown Hopkins is
focus on living being present with his
wife and kids and touring with the band
as long as he can he's even making uh
some new music so he's living oh life is
right he's still got it I love that
despite everything he's going through he
reaches over to his wife he's concerned
about her and his daughters and the
message is that he's leaving for his
daughter
also the agony of not knowing what
they're going to need exactly yes and I
like that last line of him just
strumming their guitar life is good
today I can think about yesterday we can
be worried about tomorrow but if life is
good today yes I'm smiling your face
yeah we don't know what tomorrow is none
of us do man that was awesome thanks